[Music]  let's make dynamite lumpia this is a fun  way to spice up your lumpia okay in a  food processor spring onions garlic and  some white onions then chop  now I'm using ground pork you can also  use ground chicken and add your chopped  veggies okay then add your seasonings  one teaspoon corn starch then mix  okay for my chilies I'm using Serrano  but you can also use jalapeno or even a  milder Chili Pepper but this is the only  option I have right now so this is what  we're gonna use okay so we're gonna cut  this in half and just remove the seeds  removing the seeds reduces the spice  level stuff it with a seasoned pork with  your spring roll wrapper we're gonna  fold the top for your chili fold the  bottom and we're just going to fold try  to fold as tight as you can you want it  real tight and I'm just going to seal  this with the cornstarch slurry it  should look like this then we're just  gonna fry  dip it in sweet and sour sauce it's  surprisingly not that spicy